[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone and
it's officially 2017 happy new year I'm
so excited about this new year but
January can be a pretty rough time for
movies because at the end of the year
you get this rush of great award season
films as everyone tries to get their
movies into theaters for at least a
one-week release in LA in order to
qualify for the Oscars
that leaves January pretty dire so this
week I thought what I would do is talk
about my favorite films of 2016 working
on a poem for you I love fun yeah I
guess if it's for you it's a love poem
let's start with Patterson now this is a
movie that's only just been released and
it might not be everywhere just yet but
it's a film I spoke about last week on
the show it is one of my favorite films
of 2016 because of how simple quiet and
beautiful it is it just tells a week in
the life of this bus driver played by
Adam driver he's a poet and a bus driver
and you see him just go throughout his
week and his daily rituals that he does
the same things every day and you kind
of noticed the beauty in the everyday
the beauty in the monotony and how a
simple life can actually be really nice
to see on screen I go through trillions
of molecules and move aside to make way
for me while on both sides trillions
more stay where they are
I asked it to be are you playing myself
another one of my favorite films arrival
directed by Denis Villeneuve and
starring Amy Adams Helmut this is a
sci-fi film which seems very simple on
the surface you've got this story about
a linguistics professor who's called to
try to communicate with aliens when they
land on earth but it goes so much deeper
than that I don't want to spoil the
surprise for anyone who hasn't seen it
if you haven't seen it I would say watch
it again because this is a rare film
that works just as well maybe even
better on a second viewing and yes it
does really go out there with concepts
about time but there's so much emotion
in there as well as the intellect and
Amy Adams she does such a strong
performance I love watching her on
screen and you'll be able to see arrival
coming soon at home thanks to Fandango
now it'll be out at the end of January
21 hours for me it's not little more so
how do we clarify their intentions I go
back in
well does this feel worse manchester by
the say was another favorite of mine
it's a movie that I saw at Sundance
about this time last year and it left a
huge impression on me and I've seen it
again since and every single time it
hits me in the gut with the emotion who
I have anything big to say it's okay I
just I know you've been around and I
thought just began Patrick settled in it
seems like he's doing pretty good huh
considering I think he is yeah it's a
really tough story it's the story that
you need to be in the right mindset for
starring Casey Affleck as a guy who has
to return home to look after his nephew
when his brother dies and the reason why
he has to return home is revealed to you
slowly through a set of flashbacks and
when you realize why it it is tough to
get through but there are moments of joy
and happiness and laughter and comedic
moments as well what did you decide you
can always stay with us if he wants to
come up weekends do you want to be his
guardian well he doesn't really my god
he's already got a hustle to try to
loosen ships at this point the whole
thing is just so beautifully acted and
well put together Michelle Williams
another standout and Casey Affleck I'd
say will get the Oscar this year there's
something wrong with me - want me to
call your friends what are you wanting
to do I'm not gonna bother you I just
sit there until you calm down all right
I don't calming it like you please just
go away you know
[Music]
if you know me at all then you probably
know how much I loved lala land lala
land is a film that I've seen now ten
times I'm quite obsessed with it two
options you either follow my rules or
follow my rules capiche thank you I can
do it a different way
that's that's fine thank you very much
it feels very personal to me what I love
and I know so many other people relate
to it as well because this is a film
about dreamers it stars Emma Stone and
Ryan Gosling they're a couple who are
both in LA trying to achieve their
dreams and she wants to be an actress he
wants to own a jazz club and the two
have to navigate that as well as their
relationship and there's certain things
that you might have to give up in order
to pursue your dreams and those feelings
of doubt that everyone has when they're
going after their big goals it's also a
throwback to classic musicals and ones
that I grew up watching and loving and
ones that you should definitely watch
especially now like singing in the rain
rest in peace Debbie Reynolds and it's
so full of joy at the same time it also
has some deep emotion to it lala land is
sure to be a front-runner for Oscar
nominations when they're announced later
this January
[Applause]
and one of my favorite movies of 2016
was definitely moonlight another film
that should be a front-runner at the
Oscars at some point you got to decide
for yourself if you don't let nobody
make that decision this is directed by
Barry Jenkins and it tells the story of
one man's life this guy who's living in
Miami he is dealing with his crack
addict mother the fact that he doesn't
have a father figure and the fact that
he is not sure about his sexuality and
the way it's told is so brilliant and
simple very elegant - there's three
different parts so one when he's a boy
one when he's a teenager and one where
he's a young adult all the different
actors playing these characters you get
such an overview of this one man's life
and as I said it's very subtle it's very
elegantly done beautifully shot - so
much emotion in there and for me this
was a character that I haven't really
seen that much on screen it tackles
topics that aren't usually explored on
film I thought it was something unique
and remarkable check out moonlight as
soon as you can I see you in like a
decade
it's not what I expected
what did you expect
so there you have it a quick little
episode this week with five of my
favorite films of 2016 and I want to
know yours let me know in the comments
below what were some of your favorite
films that you saw last year some of
these movies are still coming to various
places around the country so I hope you
get to catch them and they'll all be on
video on demand very very soon I'm
Alicia Malone I'll be back with more
next week but